nuclear power British steel even Pizza
Express Chinese investment in the UK is
far wider than just telecommunications
but might it be switched off as
punishment for Britain deciding to dump
Huawei one the mutual trust was
undermined it'd be difficult for you
know the businesses to have a confidence
to have a more good an era
you don't need government to say
anything I think the business they can
make their own conclusion
so I think the trust is a is a series of
damage between the country level between
the government level and among the
businesses what a difference five years
makes this was China's president on a
state visit the start of what then Prime
Minister David Cameron called a golden
era in relations but Rao's over Hong
Kong and now Huawei have heard the
harmony one of the reason and for the UK
decision people say that they had to
succumb to the pressure from these China
Hawks and China bashes you know they all
regard China is a hostile or potentially
hostile country they don't transfer
China so they don't transonic companies
China basha in chief taking full credit
for the UK YouTube we confronted
untrustworthy Chinese technology and
telecom providers we convinced many
countries many countries and I did this
myself for the most part not to use
Huawei because we think it's an unsafe
security risk not so says Beijing but
any retaliation for our way may not
actually be as harsh as the rhetoric I
think we should see high-level meetings
ministerial meetings canceled I think
their likelihood is that we should see a
cyber attacks on
on even greater number than the
mountains as normal and there will be
the usual threats against our exports
investment city of London all of which I
think actually adds up to a package that
is far less hurtful as a byte than it is
loud as a bark
why because investment in sectors like
nuclear power a good for China too but
this relationship could well fracture
further as suspicions on both sides
mount Deborah Haynes Sky News